I've traveled to the remote highlands of
Sulawesi Indonesia to witness the
unusual customs of the people of
terrassa
who makes Christianity with ancient
religious beliefs thank you for having
me a part of this okay thank you I just
came to visit I just came to visit your
grandmother my god oh my into Raja after
someone's dead but before they're buried
they're considered to be sick or still
sleeping so keeping them at home until
the burial is a common thing that gives
families time to plan and save money for
an elaborate send-off ceremony so this
is the family
okay very very beautiful the way she's
dressed yeah this uh typical Torian
dress how long has she been sleeping for
four days four days the ancestral
village of kETK who is home to stone
caves where the dead are ultimately laid
to rest I was prepared for a profound
spiritual moment but as it turns out so
are a lot of other people I was actually
under the impression that this was a you
know sacred and remote and I was
actually a bit taken back to see so many
other tourists it was like Disney World
for the dead there turned out to be
people here from all over the world what
did you come to Tasha for very nice
could you imagine tourists coming to
your funerals even Katarina who welcomed
me into her home earlier turns out she
works in the tourism industry as well at
a booth that sells death related
souvenirs you wanna dance and then you
use the head and your head show me
around show me all the things you've got
tell me something or why are there so
many knives here why kill a buffalo
yeah this is a sarong that we wear at
the funerals
let's get this buffalo head to go select
go to go it's pretty clear Trojans have
made some of their traditions into an
entire tourist industry